nos encontramos en un lugar que ha
pasado a convertirse en estratégico en
la guerra de ucrania detrás nuestro está
uno de los pasos fronterizos con
moldavia y a pocos kilómetros de aquí
está transnistria casi un cinturón un
área dentro de moldavia que nunca quiso
independizarse de la federación rusa
después de la caída de la unión
soviética cuando moldavia declaró su
independencia aquí están estacionadas al
menos mil tropas rusia si tiene está
gobernada por el gobierno de moscú no ha
tomado trascendencia en los últimos días
después del 22 de abril cuando un alto
general ruso dijo que la misión era
tomar toda la costa y llegar hasta
transitia esto terminaría por encerrar
no solamente a ucrania porque le
quitaría su acceso al mar sino también
tendría acceso a las tropas rusas para
atacar a los ucranianos desde el oeste
sin embargo los analistas dicen que esto
todavía tomará mucho tiempo si llega a
suceder las tropas rusas están
estacionadas en las cercanías de
mykolaiv a 130 kilómetros de eso incluso
los han presionado para retro era la
área de cartón sin embargo en las
declaraciones de este general volvieron
a llamar la atención
no solamente hacia moldeable sino hasta
este pedazo de tierra de transnistria
donde hay como decía mil tropas rusas
estacionadas